welcome to this video this is what you
get for fetching a drink while you have
a seat open ok so what time about 20
seconds ok it's not the end of the world
we got an advance Carol maybe this way
I'm actually playing quicker I don't
don't really know the theory of this
let's see yeah I'm a bit a bit behind in
development this looks a bit dangerous
to be honest ok i'm a bit afraid hear
about sex only six or something should
be six
yeah I don't really believe that this is
actively working but there are
possibilities yeah let's see what he's
doing that's not really working I can
always play em mb6 Bishop b6 takes
Knight takes Queen B 6 and you really
like a follow-up I think maybe you can
just play play it back to d4 and claim
long-term long-term compensation okay
but what am i doing if he is playing a
normal move which is far more likely
yeah probably night be 695
can I need to get get developed of the
slim now that's not too bad maybe Bishop
before coming with the tempo and then
castles and that's quite ok maybe you
should spend ok didn't spend the move
for a three year I was going to say yeah
well maybe my my favorite move Queen
edge for
hmm
ha interesting interesting but should be
for is going g3 I guess
yeah well I must play g3 basically I
have rookie too but this is I'm very
strange-looking booth maybe it's still
possible i'm not saying it is unplayable
let them go cute weenie 7g three queen
ism
hmm this guy is even slower than I am
that's quite remarkable always have to
take into account that I'm doing doing
the the commentary here this is strange
okay 96 ah interesting very interesting
bishop d 2 is going 96 check hmm Wow oh
that's a that's cool
hmm but it's a winning I don't know why
wait check what is what exactly is this
is the problem Queen f7 kamini twin f7
Queen I am I don't don't see it it looks
it looks yeah yeah at it it looks very
dangerous at first but upon sick but
upon a somewhat closer inspection you're
not not really sure what the threat is
maybe I should play Queen f4 aha even
Queen takes d4 was possible many
right f7 maybe night of samne contending
night takes c6
how are you say him he's really letting
the clock run down
yeah maybe just night sm right at seven
and 10 in 96 I'm not so sure what I
should reply yeah okay I can easily
return the rook here I don't I don't
need to to save all the material Queenie
for maybe we should be for you I Queenie
for 24 this looks good basically I see
has got a hard time not to trade queens
now I'm just covering the critical
square some 96 I just I just take take
with the king if i take here now i can
my queen bee 7 f9 chest 7 because the
queen is protected yeah protected white
forfeits on time yeah he spent spend
ages you know it was somehow I mean
without really intending that it was a
rather provocative way to play from my
side because I don't really have have a
good development but maybe there is no
way to really exploit it
yeah the cop gives Queen g-form here
being very very good for Wired yeah and
yeah that's in fact interesting the idea
after let's say queen d 7 is to play a
form very interesting intending a5 and
Bishop a form this is a pretty pretty
dangerous okay Kabuto has to play a five
and this looks really ugly but probably
I need to do that the problem with this
that on g4 the screen is always at
taking g-sensor I cannot go here because
of yeah caffeine g7 or or this one and
then how do I protect that I probably I
don't yeah this would have been very
very good I am I probably must avoid
Knight b6 compounds to play whoopsie aid
kill maybe they are dangerous i needed
to do something probably hear the worst
is over I hope yeah that's really cute
cat computer gives what gives this is
equal interesting with Bishop b4 and
this is what I played you instantly
incident lemon and now it wants to play
Knight takes of seven instead of taking
and gives white no but should be for now
no idea no idea what's going on here
adults I would also only trust the
computer here if you let it run for a
while because it's so messy it will give
you a
correct evaluation eventually but i'm
not sure that just letting it run for
five to ten seconds or so it's a good
good evaluation here i'm starting to
believe even without the comp that black
is just better I don't think white is
any any serious breakthrough bajo 96 is
still good for Wyatt really check Wow
why'd you write in this position meanie
was down to five seconds some and we'll
lose on time probably but knight c6 is
winning here Wow yeah I didn't I didn't
see it at all I thought he just resigns
cool very cool yeah the problem is so if
you look at this check I have
materialized I'm not not so not so bad
but the problem is she just has this
raging attack with all kinds of God
kinds of threat wow yeah compass on plus
for almost which means he will pick up
some some more material wow crazy game
okay thanks for watching